[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show i'm here i
don't know for how long we're basically
doing it day by day at this point pat
um but today i am here
and we will see sort of like how long it
lasts and honestly i mean people have
been emailing me pat saying like take
more time take more time um
you know
i want something other than bottles and
diapers in my life so it's really great
to take a couple of hours to put
together a show
because when you're in the when you're
in the trenches pat
uh even just like reading a news story
is like wow there's still other stuff
happening in the world
well yeah welcome back i hope that
you're enjoying fatherhood yeah i hope
that you're able to get some sleep
whenever you can
and
imagine you've been just super busy over
the past week but like i just i don't
really have the perspective of how much
it all entails like i don't know the
baby's probably constantly crying and
can't sleep through the night and all
these different things but you know at
least you have two people to take care
of her yeah plus the other family
members who step in yeah so yeah it's
hard for me to gauge just exactly what
your day-to-day is like i couldn't
engage it either and the the most surpr
like you understand intellectually all
the things when someone goes okay so
like listen at first
they basically eat every two hours
and you're changing like eight to ten
diapers a day
wow and particularly when you're in the
hospital someone's gonna come knocking
on the door every 15 minutes it's like
you know the nurse the vital signs
people the pediatrician the ob
the room service food the person picking
up the room service food trays the
person changing the trash can the person
who has to register the baby with social
security that you know it's literally
ever and then it just starts over again
you know um so there's that but the
thing that really is crazy is sort of
like okay
so like
when is it time for us to sleep in the
sense of like this process just goes on
24 7.
so do you go well at the after the 9 pm
cycle
are we both sleeping or not and then
when you when you get home
the
is the baby alive right now starts and
that is not the most conducive thing to
sleep
yeah just a constant pressure and i'd
imagine you're going to continue feeling
that way for uh the next 18 years yeah
exactly even longer because you're
constantly going to have to worry about
how your child is doing yeah but maybe
to some degree you'll get used to it are
you able to sleep in like little shifts
are you able to take little naps here
and there because personally i
absolutely hate that i need my eight
hours of rest and it has to be in a row
yeah but you don't always get to choose
when you're gonna sleep when you have a
newborn no you don't so the new strategy
has sort of been like at around 9 00 p.m
uh it my shift starts so in an ideal
world 9 p.m
my girlfriend goes to bed
i'm just you know kind of up with the
baby hoping to get her to go to sleep
for like a few hours in one of the
various contraptions that we have you
know to put a baby in but like
everything just takes forever so instead
even though my shift starts at nine like
my girlfriend doesn't actually go to bed
until eleven so like i'm already two
hours into my shift and it just it just
gets derailed like crazy
um and then when we get to like okay 1am
is when supposedly
my girlfriend takes over
and tries to get the baby to sleep
ever for a couple hours at a time and
then like for whatever reason the baby
is just up much more at night than
during the day which i think is common
at first because it's like when the mom
is sleeping there's no motion so the
baby is in the womb so the baby's more
awake so it's like almost like the
baby's born on a reverse schedule and it
can take six weeks to get on like a
normal schedule it's all crazy and
nobody like intellectually you can
understand all of it but until you're in
the trenches it's it's impossible to
really even get it
oh yeah your life has definitely changed
over the past week or so yeah and uh you
also had a 38-year long streak going of
never changing a diaper yeah
that's that's over with now i did have
to change one yeah yeah
and you know unfortunately it's pretty
bad it's pretty bad um but you know one
of the it like all i guess babies i
guess fart a lot it's pretty crazy
but when the farting starts it was like
uh the firebombing of dresden started
you know it was like a big battle in
world war ii or whatever things get very
real at that point in time
um no but it's it's great i recommend it
to everybody
i'm of course not a father but i am an
uncle yeah and when my niece and nephew
were little babies i would love to go
over the house and like hold them for a
while but yeah whenever i heard that
farting sound that that was when it was
time to hand over the baby right for the
parents not my responsibility that's why
it's so great to be an uncle because you
get to like enjoy all the fun parts but
then when the challenging times come up
you get to pass the responsibility over
the other thing that's really tough is
everyone has an opinion everyone on any
there's nothing related to babies that
there aren't 10 different opinions on
how long should they be feeding should
you or shouldn't you wake them up to
feed if they sleep more than you expect
and some say no you got to wake them up
so that you keep their weight up and
also it'll make them sleep longer at
night and others go no no no no the more
they sleep the more they will sleep
which is what i've read a couple books
i'm more partial to that
i think at this point the more they get
used to sleeping the more easily they
will sleep even more they have an
incredible ability to sleep you know
it's not like an adult where most
people's maximum over a week is about
eight hours a day like you might be able
to sleep 12 hours one day you'll it's
probably because you slept less there's
this natural limit it's not that way
with babies they can sleep a lot more so
you know there's nothing you can find
that people will just say this is the
this is the one way
everybody has an opinion yeah that must
be incredibly annoying because then you
feel as though you're doing it wrong no
matter what you do because there's
another school of thought on just about
everything yeah and i like how you're
partial to the idea of just letting the
baby sleep because that means that you
get a little bit more rest too
so that works out well i should also ask
i mean your baby's very young of course
only a week old at this point but are
there uh aspects of her personality that
you've been able to pick up
during this time or is it just too early
to tell any of that it's too it's too i
mean you know she barely has her eyes
open you know it's uh it's very very
hard i'm sure that that i could say
things but at this point who knows if
they're just reflexes you know what i
mean
have you told her about trump yet or no
have you offered her a position at the
show or anything like that no no no no
no not yet i'm waiting at least until uh
you know she sleeps through the night in
order in order to warn her about that
um so i'm trying to think what else i
mean you know it's just even just like
when do we have dinner starts to become
a really crazy question because you know
you want to plan for a certain time
especially if you're having warm food
around noon as uh the judge in wisconsin
would say during the written house trial
but it just
the baby might not be sleeping at noon
you just can't really control that right
i have such a difficult time even just
taking care of myself like wrapping all
my meals making sure i'm getting a
shower in making sure i'm sleeping
enough getting to the gym when i can if
i have to take care of another human
being all that stuff has to
not necessarily go out the window but it
comes second right so even something
like making dinner are you are you
having takeout are you eating out like
as much as you can are you having family
members bringing you food there's been a
mix that helps a lot i actually was able
in the middle of this entire thing to
make uh eggs and french toast one
morning
which was great it was like being normal
again
but um there's some eating out and then
there's been some delivered food and
yeah you know it's just it's just a mix
you're basically just in survival mode
at this point yeah it's a sign of
normalcy for you just like hosting
today's show is right and uh you know if
you're not able to host the entire week
we understand we can fill in we have
guest hosts on standby and it sounds
like most in our audience understand
like probably 95 plus the audience
understand but then there were some of
those people who were absolutely
outraged that you decided to take off uh
time off because you had a baby yeah i
don't know what is going through those
people's minds because you'd think that
as progressives they would be in favor
of enjoying this quality time with the
little one and paternity leave and child
care and all these different things but
no they need to have the david pakman
show and they need to have david hosting
it it doesn't matter what's going on in
his life depressing because it's you
know i thought our side was in favor of
that but what i will say is i'm not back
today because of those people i just
really wanted to host the show and get a
break from just baby stuff and there's
been so much going on in the news that
i'm glad to be able to you know spend a
couple hours doing it soon i'll be at
the pediatrician so don't lest anyone be
concerned i'm jumping right back into
baby stuff but that's what's going on
and i'm sure every day uh we'll we'll
bring some kind of new thing the one
thing that's not going on is i guess
she's just too little right now for any
any like spitting up you know when she
gets burped it's just like the tiniest
little burp and there's no projectile
but at some point i think that the
burping becomes extremely weaponized and
we'll have to see what happens then you
know
i didn't know too much about that uh so
you have to burp the babies because they
are unable to do it on their own no
i mean listen again anything i say 10
people will email giving telling me why
i'm wrong my understanding is
for the most part babies if they need to
burp they will burp on their own it just
might take a while and they might be
uncomfortable so the idea is you just
kind of help it along by either tapping
the baby's back or kind of shifting them
forward and back in a particular way
you have training on how not to burp
when you're hosting the show right right
because that can really interrupt things
you kind of like i don't know if you
swallow it or what exactly is going on
there honestly i don't really have
trouble
it i just rarely feel the need to burp
during the show i don't know that i have
any special technique to be totally
honest
that always throws me off whenever i
have to do a little hosting here and
there i'm like do i start the segment
over do i just keep going because like
you know that that can derail things for
sure yeah that's uh fortunately not an
issue that is that that i've struggled
with but so i'll keep people posted
that's the latest uh baby update but by
the way i do want to talk a little bit
about what's going on in the news
yesterday i had a moment to just kind of
see like oh what what ended up happening
with inflation like catch up on the last
nine days of the economy essentially
because i just missed it all
and stocks completely falling off a
cliff now we're talking about recession
fears the s p 500 has entered uh bear
market territory there's been a massive
crypto crash now people are waiting for
um uh we're waiting on jobs numbers
we're waiting on a lot of different
things
i still have no special insight you know
i joked i'm not going to make a
prediction about whether we're heading
towards a recession but this is an
extraordinarily choppy economy right now
and almost anything could happen i have
no insight into what will happen but i
wouldn't be surprised at just about any
outcome
yeah i feel like you have to have two
different minds whenever you're trying
to predict what's going to happen in the
economy or stock market or any of this
stuff you have to have like the purely
logical mind of like oh well over a
20-year period it's going to go up and
you know long-term everything's going to
be fine just keep buying in and all that
stuff and then you can have like the
secondary opinion that really shouldn't
uh weigh in your decision-making when it
comes to investing but you might think
like oh well because of inflation i
think we're going to head down a little
bit more because interest rates are
going to go up or there's this other
macro indicator we have to look at or
whatever else but yeah again like you
should have the first uh point of view
when it comes to that influence your
decision making and just try to keep a
level head with all this stuff
and you know that being said my sense is
that for as long as inflation is ticking
up to the degree that is we're probably
going to have these troubled waters with
the market and everything you know maybe
if it starts to head back down if the
june inflation numbers are a little bit
more positive meaning heading downwards
maybe stocks will rebound but who knows
at this point it's been six months of
downtrend and that can very much
continue i am just going to keep buying
and uh the lower stocks go the lower my
cost basis i and it's not it's not any
big insight it's just i
if i don't keep buying
i'm missing my asset allocation which is
you know i'm not holding a crazy amount
of cash or other stuff
um and so since i don't know where the
bottom is the bottom could be yes could
it could have been yesterday could be
today it could be next week or it could
be in three months
all i can do is well let me keep my
asset allocation
and if stocks go down i'm lowering my
average cost basis there's really
nothing else to do you know
yeah i mean some people panic sell they
freak out they think it's going to go
lower and so they get out some people
think that they can get out with the
idea that they can get back in later
yeah but the problem with that is
oftentimes the factors that played into
you panic selling are the same ones that
prevent you from buying if correct do go
lower and so it just doesn't make sense
it's like a lot of people do the
opposite of what they should be doing
right instead of buying low and selling
high if they need to well they'll
they'll buy high and sell low so it's
one of those things but the good news
with this downtrend is that we now all
have less money to lose true because
we've lost so much over the past six
months or so so that's that's the bright
side with all of this schedule on the
timing thing you mentioned uh in the
recession of uh 2008
a ton of people lost a lot of money
because they got scared out of the
market
it wasn't clear that we had hit bottom
until about a few months later
and some of the biggest gains were in
those months you know there's these
stats about how
some overwhelming amount of the gains
happen on relatively few days of the
year you've got a bunch of these two
three four percent pops and if you miss
those 10 days out of the year you lose a
large share of the gains and i i don't
have any special skill to know when
those days are going to be so i'm just
staying in the market it's the right
thing for my age and my asset allocation
and my outlook but it is it is it is
scary out there i understand it yeah and
the same can be said for the 2020 crash
when kovitz started yeah we're at the
bottom plenty of people didn't think we
were at the bottom yet because we still
had cases going up and we still had a
bunch of uncertainty and the thing is
when the market starts to head back up
people think oh well it's just going to
retrace or this is just a dead cat
bounce or whatever which it could be any
of those things but oftentimes it turns
out to just be the reversal and then you
miss the boat so yeah i mean don't don't
be panic selling unless you absolutely
need the money and if you are in a
position like that you probably over
invested to begin with you probably are
investing stuff where you you need the
money right away and you shouldn't be
putting it in that sort of basket for
the long term anyway there is the one
scenario
where
i could imagine these are like really
specific scenarios
where let's say and i'm going to give a
counter point to my own scenario but
let's say you're about to buy a house
right and you
you have a cash down payment saved up
but you currently have some
um stocks and bonds on which you have a
loss because you started buying in
january and then stocks went down and
then you bought in february and stocks
went down so you have a loss there
you could speak to an accountant about
the possibility if your broker or mutual
fund company lets you sell specific lots
you could sell
the lots you've lost money on which
gives you a tax deduction that gives you
a write-off and use that money for your
down payment that could give you that
would be a reason to sell some right i
mean but but again you have to
counterbalance that with well
those might be lots on which i will get
large gains if i just wait and then the
other counterpoint of course is
if you thought you might have needed
that money for a home down payment it
shouldn't have been in stocks to begin
with right like i understand that
there's counterpoints to all these
things but there might be someone who
would say hey you know what i want to
take the loss and get a tax deduction
and use the money to buy a house for
example i could understand that
yeah the tax loss harvesting that can
make sense and sometimes people just do
it so that you know they're able to
deduct three thousand dollars for
the first year and then they're able to
roll that over into future years and
then maybe you buy back in after the
30-day period is up where you're allowed
to do that so that can definitely make
sense for your circumstance but i think
yeah the broader point about just having
the right asset allocation depending on
your life circumstances yep that's what
really stands up it doesn't matter if
the market's going up or down if you
need the cash on the sidelines because
you're going to be buying a house soon
then make sure you have that if you're
going to be retiring soon so you
shouldn't be overly invested in stocks
and you should have more bonds in your
portfolio you should be doing that but
it shouldn't be changing on a whim no
like what portion of what is in uh
stocks crypto whatever else based on how
things are going 100
100
all right let's see how things look
tomorrow from the standpoint of baby and
from the standpoint of economy
uh we'll see everybody very soon thank
you